You got to play the game.
And sometimes even from you,
when you just said to me,
you don't,
like you just said to wow,
you know,
sometimes you,
you,
it's not right to turn a blind eye on things.
And it's like
sometimes you have to,
if you want to get yourself to a position like mine seems
to me that you're making a distinction between discipline and strategy,
like and,
and,
and like impulsive,
moral responding.
You know,
like let's say that you are in a situation where you have a boss who's
intolerable and maybe what you'd like to do,
you know,
the resentment is built up over five years and you'd like to go in there and,
and yell at him and tell him everything you think and you think,
well that's the truth.
It's like,
well,
it's actually,
it's not a very sophisticated truth because you're doing a shallow and impulsive
analysis of the situation.
Like it would have been the case that you've already compromised yourself in 500
ways.
And I'll get back to the playing the game issue because you do have to
discipline yourself to,
and,
and you have to discipline yourself to,
to some degree,
by allowing yourself to do arbitrary things that are part of the system,
right?
That's necessary part of discipline.
And discriminating that from a compliance with unethical activity is very
difficult.
So that's a hard situation.
But let's say you're,
you're,
you're going to counsel someone who has an intolerable boss and they'd come in
and they're right at the end of their tether because maybe that's why they come
for counseling.
They say,
I really want to tell that son of a bitch what I think of him.
And you think,
well,
wait a second here.
Okay,
first of all,
you've already eradicated from the list of reasonable possibilities.
That decision by failing to say small things that you could have said all the
way along.
And it's not like you can just all of a sudden blurt all of that out now.
And that wipes the slate clean in.
That constitutes truth.
It's too unsophisticated.
So let's think,
okay,
so what is it that you want?
Well,
I don't want this job anymore.
It's like,
okay,
now let's,
let's actually have a strategy about this.
Then you don't want this job anymore.
Can you get another job?
While I don't think so.
Well,
so you can't just quit.
no I can't because then I don't have any money in my family.
Depends on the job.
It's like,
okay,
so you can't just stop this.
That's not a viable solution.
You go out of the frying pan into the fire or you know,
you sack you s you substitute one set of unethical actions for another set of
unethical actions that are even worse.
That's not helpful.
All right,
so let's start thinking about what exactly it is that you want.
It's like,
well maybe I want a better job.
I want to work for someone who's more reasonable.
Okay,
so what's stopping you?
Well,
I don't have my CV in order.
My resume isn't up to date.
Well,
why is that?
While I haven't done it for five years and I don't like doing it.
Well,
why is that?
Well because I'm kind of embarrassed about it because it has holes in it and it
shows where I'm lackadaisical and where I'm not prepared.
It's like,
okay,
how many things are there like that?
While there's a bunch of things and they're all associated with how I
procrastinated in the past,
it's like,
okay,
what are we going to do to rectify that?
So I'll say to people,
why don't you update your CV death?
That's what we'll do first.
Because if you're going to look for a different job,
I'm not saying you're going to look for a different job,
but if you're going to look for a different job,
you're not going to,
unless your cvs updated,
you go going to,
unless you can get a good recommendation from this boss that's a tyrant.
That's right.
There's you gotta play the,
there's 10 strategic actions that you're going to have to take in order to make
yourself able to move laterally or up.
And the truth is isn't going in and yelling at your boss and telling him
everything you think about them.
The truth is trying to figure out the very,
very difficult process of how you put yourself in a better position.
And that that are like,
one of the things that's quite fun about this lecture tour is the letters that I
received or the stories that people tell me about switching jobs because they do
realize that there,
and I often talk to people about consulting their resentment.
Resentments are really useful emotion.
Like it's really dangerous.
It's one of the most dangerous psychological states,
I believe.
But it's unbelievably useful because resentment usually only means one of two
things.
It either means quit whining and,
and take it on because you're immature or it means you're allowing yourself to
be taken advantage of and you have something to say or do.
And so you want to sort out the first part and find out if you're just being
immature and you can think that through and you can talk to people.
Um,
but,
and that,
but if it's the second,
it's like,
no,
you've compromised yourself in a variety of ways and you have to figure out how
to get out of that.
And if you're resentful,
that's evidence that you have in fact done that.
Okay,
so now the issue would be,
well how can you set your life up so that you can be without that resentment?
And so that's when you start to develop a strategy for you know,
and,
and it,
there's actually an adventure in this too.
I mean I've had a number of clients who have been in jobs that they didn't like
it all and you know,
they were tyrannized by someone for example,
and they were also working below their hypothetical level and we'd put together
a plan.
It's like,
okay,
you're going to make three times as much money in five years.
That's the Plat.
But like that's not going to be simple.
So you,
there's education,
you got to educate yourself maybe formerly cause you've got holes,
you got to fix up your resume,
you've got to,
you've got to overcome your fear of being interviewed.
You have to start sending out like 50 resumes a week on a regular basis and be
prepared for a 99% rejection rate.
You're going to look for a different job in is probably going to take six months
to a year and almost all of that is going to be rejection.
And you go to steel yourself from for that and prepare and maybe this is going
to be a three year process.
It's no trivial thing,
but you know,
it's almost inevitably can't remember a single example where the consequence of
that very careful,
detailed strategic thinking wasn't a massively substantive improvement in
socioeconomic positioning and a great movement towards a UN on improving
trajectory and,
and,
and there's advantages even along the way because even before that happens,
the fact that you're taking genuine steps to put yourself in a better situation
immediately starts to reduce your resentment,
even if it isn't having positive consequences to begin with.
But you have to be realistic about it.
It's like,
look,
it's going to be hard to update your CV because you're embarrassed about it and
you should be right.
It's no wonder you're embarrassed about it.
And then,
well,
of course you don't want to go be interviewed because you're not very good at
it.
And,
and there's holes in your story and,
and your,
and you can be made nervous easily and you're not a very good advocate for
yourself.
So there's a lot of improvement that needs to be done there.
And,
uh,
and then you have to withstand the,
the,
the punishment of being constantly rejected when you apply for jobs because the
baseline rejection rate,
you know,
for the,
for the typical job,
applicant is like 99%.
It's like the rejection rate for everything.
Is this gonna work?
No,
but if you do it a hundred times,
it might work once and that's all you need.
That's exactly it.
You,
you,
you only need that once.
And so the truth there isn't to yell at your boss.
The truth there is to get your life together.
Yeah.